[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du grand jt des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité de ce journal le
top départ des vacances d'été c'est dans
quelques jours en attendant les
touristes et vacanciers les
professionnels peaufinent leur
préparation a eu l'exemple en savoie à
suivre dans quelques instants avec la
rédaction de 8 mont blanc hausse de la
taxe foncière et plafonnement des loyers
les propriétaires immobiliers sont
inquiets dans ce journal nous serons en
duplex avec christophe de marsan le
président de l'union nationale des
propriétaires immobilier qui nous
expliquera pourquoi cette hausse de
l'année on la disait effacé et distante
elle a connu la proximité du pouvoir
suprême mais aussi les trahisons de la
vie politique
l'ex première dame de france anne aymone
giscard d'estaing ne s'était jamais
exprimé à la télévision en exclusivité
elle sera mon invité samedi prochain le
9 juillet à 22h pour une édition
spéciale de l'émission territoire de
france dans ce journal un avant goût de
cet entretien exclusif qu'elle m'a
accordé à pied et le dos courbé la pêche
aux coques débute dans la bête de somme
la rédaction de wéo tv la chaîne du
groupe la voix du nord a suivi dans un
décor féerique les pêcheurs de ce
mollusque de très belles images enfin
d'édition
dès le week-end prochain vous serez
nombreux à prendre la route des vacances
c'est que ce soit en direction de la mer
de la montagne ou de la campagne les
professionnels du tourisme attendent
évidemment cette saison avec impatience
dans la vallée des belleville en savoie
vous allez le voir l'heure est aux
derniers préparatifs
parcours vtt randonnée ou aventure rien
n'est laissé au hasard comme a pu le
constater perrine aubert de la rédaction
de 8 mont blanc
c'est la course avant l'ouverture des
stations le 3 juillet pour la saison
estivale à val thorens on sert autant on
remonte les douze ateliers de ce
parcours montagne à flanc de rocher
décroché en septembre dernier cette
passerelle à passer l'hiver sous la
neige et après un rapide coup d'oeil sur
les éventuels dommages elle retrouve
enfin les airs on fait ça avec des tirs
fort
en temps et on raccroche tout simplement
donc tout le montage et un démontage du
ateliers sont faits depuis longtemps il
a juste allait raccrocher tout ça est
vérifiée pour la dernière semaine de
juin tout ça et tout en place chaque
année ça fait comme ça sur les sentiers
les 700 panneaux de signalisation sont
remis en place et on vérifie s'ils sont
bien installés une quinzaine de
personnes travaillent depuis un mois et
demi à la réinstallation des équipements
et de nouveaux aménagements prennent ans
informe qu'un peu de terre là qui va
nous ramener ça va ça va me poser le
terrain parce que l'été les touristes
viennent marcher mais également faire du
vtt cette pratique est au coeur de la
stratégie des menuires et au pied de la
station un terrain d'apprentissage est
créé pour que les amateurs de sensations
fortes puis se tester en vélo en fait
c'est exactement pareil au niveau des
couleurs donc vert bleu rouge noir par
contre c'est pas du tout les pistes de
ski qu'on utilise ces des pistes qui
sont spécifiques pour le vtt et rien
n'est laissé au hasard nous ce qu'on
aime en gros pour le vtt l'été c'est
qu'il faut qu'il y ait des mouvements
terrain que ce soit fun
donc là on doit créer voilà des
mouvements de terrain sur une zone qui
est très plate donc voilà c'est un petit
challenge mais ça va le faire l'automne
venu les pistes de vtt seront remises à
plat est rebouché en attendant l'hiver
et les skieurs
voilà et malheureusement cet été comme
chaque année des millions de français
n'auront pas la chance de partir en
vacances c'est justement pour lutter
contre cette ségrégation que la
fondation abbé pierre propose des
séjours à la mer pour les personnes les
plus précaires et les sans abri près de
450 d'entre eux viennent de profiter
d'ailleurs de plusieurs jours a7 près de
montpellier au programme activités
détente et sourire aux lèvres un sujet
de justin baro pour vient occitanie
pour certains vacanciers c'est la
première fois qu'il voit la mer
cette semaine les habitants des pensions
de famille de la fondation abbé pierre
et les personnes sans abri reçu un
accueil de jour ont pu bénéficier de
cinq jours de vacances à 7 au programme
de nombreuses activités comme le pad
c'est la première fois c'est la première
fois que tu sais pas facile c'est un
vrai exercice de padum on est censé se
détendre alors quand on voit les jets au
démarrage ne sont pas très détendu sont
tous les genoux comme ça venant de toute
la france ils sont 450 à bénéficier de
cette initiative de la fondation avec
l'aide de l'association montpelliéraine
g star une aubaine pour ceux qui ne
peuvent pas habituellement s'offrir des
vacances nous étions des ardents à paris
et vu notre situation sociale tout au
tout avec la famille avec le bd donc la
mairie nous a conduits vers cette
association qui est les maillots et
voilà que on a trouvé notre bonheur
parce que voilà grâce à u on est un
logement grâce à urnes à des vacances
encadrés par des référents associatif
qu'ils connaissent dans une résidence de
vacances ces personnes mal logées
prennent le temps de s'échapper le temps
de quelques jours de leur quotidien une
dure réalité qui parfois les rattrape
face à la mer
certaines personnes qui notamment dix
jeunes migrants qui ont qui sont arrivés
en france il ya quelques années par le
bar des bateaux dans des conditions
parfois ses sorties de bain se retrouve
à nouveau confronté à à ces situations
donc on a on a bien évidemment prévu de
les accompagner de les aider à
dépasser ces traumatismes ce projet de
vacances existe à 7 depuis quatre ans
avec le programme 7 à toi il est financé
entièrement par les dons récoltés par la
fondation abbé pierre
et qui dit été dit également sécurité
c'est pour sensibiliser les plaisanciers
aux dangers des loisirs nautiques que
les autorités effectuent des opérations
de contrôle un peu partout sur le
territoire outre le manque d'entretien
ou l'excès de vitesse un nouveau fléau
est apparu sur les littoraux la conduite
sans permis reportage sur le bassin
d'arcachon divan branchies pour tv7 la
chaîne du groupe sud ouest
cette fois ci rien à signaler brassière
de sécurité sur le corps zone de
navigation respecter et surtout en
possession d'un permis bateau une
évidence de prime abord mais cette
saison les autorités remarque une hausse
de la conduite sans permis une
infraction qui relève notamment du pénal
nous ne pouvons plus appliqué une
procédure administrative nous
transmettons directement au tribunal
ont mis au parquet pour le pour les
poursuites enquête ça peut être
un phénomène nouveau qui inquiète les
autorités à la proche de l'été même si
elles ne représentent aujourd'hui qu'une
dizaine d'infractions par an la conduite
sans permis entraînent souvent des excès
de vitesse surtout avec l'attraction
phare des plaisanciers ce sont surtout
les jets qui sont concernés par
effectivement la conduite sans permis
alors qu'autant pour la vitesse on peut
dire que c'est à peu près équivalent ici
il est assez facile d'aller vite surtout
dans les zones dans les zones à 5 noeuds
dans la dans la bande des 300 mètres
donc autant sur sur la vitesse on est on
est bien répartie là sur la conduite
sans permis sont les jet skis deux
autres journées de sécurité en mer comme
celle ci seront organisées cet été afin
d'informer sur cette pratique et des
dangers de la mer l'année dernière plus
de 2600 contrôles ont été menés en
gironde ayant abouti à 330 et une
infraction
hausse de l'inflation plafonnement des
loyers ou encore augmentation de la taxe
foncière les sujets de tensions sont
légion en ce moment sur le marché
immobilier pour en parler nous sommes en
duplex avec christophe de merson le
président de l'ump y l'union nationale
des propriétaires immobilier
christophe de mer son bonjour d'abord le
gouvernement vient d'annoncer la mise en
place d'un bouclier loyer jusqu'en juin
2000 23 les prix des loyers nous
pourrons augmenter de plus de 3,5 pour
cent cette mesure vous parait-elle juste
pour soutenir le pouvoir d'achat des
français
bonjour cyril tout d'abord merci de
m'avoir invité alors ce qu'on peut dire
c'est que c'est un compromis
il ya eu des négociations je rappelle
que l'ump y a été consultée c'est une
bonne chose
ce qui se passe en réalité c'est que
bruno le maire a été attachée à une
mesure équitable et je lui ai rappelé
ainsi qu'amélie de montchalin que en
matière d'équité je pense que les
propriétaires avaient déjà largement
fait un grand pas puisque je rappelle
qu'il ya une réforme complète de la taxe
d'habitation l'état les taxes foncières
cette fois ci ont explosé jeudi bien
exploser avec des chiffres qui sont
énormes et ça c'est directement les
propriétaires qui sont un impact est ce
qu'on peut dire c'est que c'est un
compromis qu'en est-il de l'encadrement
des loyers est ce une mesure efficace
selon vous elle sera déployée à partir
du 15 juillet à bordeaux notamment
l'encadrement des loyers c'est un
marqueur politique
l'encadrement des loyers je rappais
c'est une expérience qui n'a jamais
marché nulle part dans le monde et enfin
ce qu'on peut dire pour faire court
c'est que l'encadrement des loyers
khalid et au delà du slogan c'est un une
machine perdante pour le locataire
puisque ça contre 1 l'offre locative et
c'est une machine perdant pour le
propriétaire puisqu'il sait plus où il
en est et il arrête de faire des travaux
et il entre yared entretenir son
patrimoine et de proposer des biens
intéressant et confortable pour ses
locataires
christophe de mer sont pour aider les
propriétaires vous demander au
gouvernement que la hausse de la taxe
foncière soit elle aussi plafonnées
pourquoi
pour une raison simple
j'allais dire que on observe salue 'une
pays observe çà de presse qu'on a
observée sur les dix dernières années
c'est une explosion des taxes foncières
comme j'en parlais tout à l'heure et
cette explosion en chiffre ainsi à ce
matériel si elle se matérialise au
niveau français c'est 30 % sur les dix
dernières années c'est 30 % ils
correspondent à trois fois l'inflation
et trois fois l'augmentation des loyers
donc ce n'est plus tenable est ce qu'on
peut dire aussi c'est qu'il ya un enjeu
bien sûr pour les propriétaires
bailleurs les propriétaires occupants ne
pourront plus habiter dans les centres
lille et dans la métropole puisque on
voit que cette explosion des taxes
foncières
n'est pas supportable par la plupart des
français voilà merci christophe de merci
pour vos réponses je rappelle que vous
êtes le président de l'union nationale
des propriétaires immobilier très bel
été à vous le reste de l'actualité
marquée par le début timide des soldes
estivales en france les moins 30 les
moins 40 les -50% n'attire pas pour
l'instant les foules dans les magasins
témoignages et reportages dans la loire
avec anthony vers pillon journalistes de
tl7 sur place bon alors ça commence tout
juste mais effectivement que ça soit sur
internet ou en boutique pour l'instant
c'est plutôt calme les autres années
effectivement à 10h30 la porte se
poussaient et les clientes attendaient
les bonnes affaires et les quelques
clientes qui ont poussé la porte ne sont
pas convaincus certaines ont déjà trouvé
leur bonne affaire il y a une semaine
ont fait les choux pu tout le temps mais
les les soldes aussi ses suivants pu
bien et aussi les ventes privées avant
les soldes j'ai fait les du mais je peux
faire et ventes privées parce que y'a
plein de choses il ya plein d'artistes
et pour tenter de contrer cette tendance
chacun essaie de trouver une parade on
n'attend pas la deuxième démarque avant
on attendait là les attendaient la
deuxième démarque pour venir et
maintenant j'ai fait du moins 40 au
moins cinq ans départ sur internet pour
l'instant c'est plutôt calme aussi où on
attendait une cinquantaine de vente sur
la journée pour l'instant on est à la
moitié ok vapeur cravacher un lieu où
les soldes sont moins subi c'était la
boutique des verts ici on affiche des
prix défiant toute concurrence pour
écouler les stocks avant l'arrivée d'un
nouveau logo et d'un nouvel
équipementier je suis passé un peu par
hasard
je découvre les prix cassés les t-shirts
110 euros suivant les tailles les
ceintures c'est 10 euros voilà j'ai pris
actuellement les baskets élu ballon de
fou que sweet way un peu de tout quoi à
bas par rapport au prix d'avant oui
c'est des prix intéressants un exemple
le ballon était à 20 euros ou 10 à 5
les soldats eux se déroule jusqu'au 19
juillet partout dans la loire
voilà il vous reste encore un peu plus
de deux semaines pour tenter de faire de
bonnes affaires et l homme le plus
rapide de l'ouest et même du monde sur
500 m florian madec un brestois peut
frôler les 70 km heure sur l'eau grâce à
sa planche équipé d'un fol une prouesse
technique qu'il doit à son expertise et
à celle d'un ami rencontre à toute
allure avec frédéric lorenzo de la
rédaction de tv ont lâché du groupe
télégramme en bretagne
en silence et glisse au fond de la rade
de brest à une vitesse folle ce jour là
le vent souffle à 25 noeuds mais florian
madec va beaucoup plus vite 36 noeuds
près de 70 km/heure à un mètre au-dessus
de l'eau grâce à son fol après près de
trois heures de navigation dans le vent
fort pour petit milliard
si on a la vmax donc la vitesse maximum
sur deux secondes donc sur une seconde
donc 37 20 j'aimerais bien aussi
possible passez les 49 ce serait beau en
v-max quoi parce que sur 500 mètres ça
va être compliqué avec un record à plus
de 36 de soixante six noeuds sur 500 m
en février dernier florian est le plus
rapide de brest et du monde 4 même s'il
a un très bon niveau florian n'a en
théorie le gabarit pour atteindre une
telle vitesse pour connaître son secret
on retrouve le planchiste dans son autre
univers florian a monté cette entreprise
de composites de pointe il y a vingt ans
mais sûr de la production
deux pièces en matériaux composites pour
la défense pour
l'aéronautique l'océanographie aidé de
son ami jean baptiste docteur en
mécanique des fluides mais également
planchistes ils affinent leur folle et
leurs connaissances depuis maintenant
plusieurs années en multipliant les
essais le fait que je sois peut-être
moins puissant moins lourd mais je le
compense par de la finesse
d'un avis du problème donc
l'amélioration
quel est le principal comment désormais
lorsqu'il se met à l'eau le tenace
florian madec à cet objectif atteindre
et dépasser largement la vitesse du vent
vous respecter son adversaire découvrir
le goût de l'effort et apprendre à se
surpasser la pratique du sport c'est
bien connu permet d'acquérir des valeurs
pour toute la vie à limoges vous allez
le voir les arts martiaux constitue un
levier d'apprentissage pour les jeunes
des quartiers populaires une nouvelle
salle dédiée à leur pratique vient
d'être inauguré boxe self défense mma
mêmes jitsu brésilien ils sont pratiqués
par tous reportage de benjamin delmas
pour cet aliment je regardais
permettre une plus grande pratique du
sport dans le quartier de la bastide
c'est l'un des objectifs de la nouvelle
infrastructure dédiée aux sports de
combat inaugurée dans le pôle de
services
au programme boxe karaté self défense
lutte et même ju jitsu brésilien on va
lancer à la rentrée une section ju jitsu
brésilien en plus du judo donc soit pour
les judokas qui ont envie de se
perfectionner au sol pour les gens qui
n'ont pas forcément envie de faire du
judo mais qui sont intéressés par le ju
jitsu brésilien pratique sportive est
essentiel pour les jeunes d'autant plus
dans les quartiers populaires car elle
représente un outil d'éducation et de
transmission
cette salle va permettre d'apporter des
valeurs de transmettre des valeurs avec
pour les jeunes de ce quartier leur
apprend le respect le courage
et pu boxer ce nouvel équipement sportif
va permettre d'élargir le panel des
sports proposés et ainsi d'augmenter le
nombre de licenciés mais déjà on a une
augmentation de créneaux donc ça
permettra à nous pour les compétitions
les sports de loisirs de pouvoir avoir
une plage horaire assez étendue ça nous
permettra de plus développer le club de
proposer aussi d'autres disciplines
parce qu'on fait aussi du mma ont fait
pas mal de self défense ainsi de suite
donc ça permettait effectivement au aux
usagers et aux limougeauds de pouvoir
avoir une plage d'horaires et des offres
beaucoup plus large en favorisant
l'accès au sport dans le quartier
l'infrastructure favorisera également
l'émergence de futurs talents moi je
pense que vous savez dans les quartiers
sensibles
souvent il ya des jeunes qui sont un peu
déscolarisés des désoeuvrés et on arrive
à trouver des champions dans ces
jeunes-là faut juste leur les mettre en
confiance leur faire confiance et puis
des fois il ya cette étincelle qui
surgit
ils étaient eux aussi les rois des
sports de combats à l'époque des romains
les gladiateurs fascine encore petits et
grands mais que sait-on réellement de
leur vie et c'est pour en savoir un peu
plus justement est dépassé et les idées
reçues qu'une compagnie d'artistes
proposer des démonstrations dans une
arène lorraine construite à la fin du
premier siècle celle ci pouvait
accueillir jusqu'à dix sept mille
spectateurs autour 2000 en arrière avec
livia boucher et denis o'cain de vosges
télévision
armé de son gladius est protégé par son
casque et son bouclier se mirent
millions fait face intras au coeur de
l'arène de l'amphithéâtre de grand petit
bond dans le passé avec les gladiateurs
d'acta au programme ateliers école de
gladiateurs et ses combats spectacle qui
se rapproche tout maximum de la réalité
a essayé de revenir un petit peu sûrs
qu'ils étaient réellement les
gladiateurs au delà des clichés qu'on a
avec les films comme gladiator et
apprend à faire une démonstration de ses
combats ce sont des combats qui sont
issus de ce qu'on appelle l'archéologie
expérimentale
donc là on essaie vraiment de comprendre
les gestes nous montrer des gestes
probable rapport au document publié donc
le cinéma copé loigné de la réalité
qu'ont connu les gladiateurs ont peu
touché entailler blessée mais pas tuée
s'il ya vraiment un élément à se
rappeler c'est que les combats les
lecteurs c'est un spectacle se combattre
à mort d offrir un spectacle ça ne peut
pas fonctionner ensemble un spectacle
qui semblait en tout cas faire
l'unanimité chez les près de 150
personnes présentes ce matin là et le
porte d'entrée aussi pour découvrir
l'histoire c'est pas la première fois
que je vois c'est toujours très
intéressant et très instructif très
pédagogique aussi retenu bas qu'on s'est
plaint de combat j'avais aussi des chips
et des combats des femmes en effet bien
qu'elle ait été oublié par l'histoire
des gladiatrice ont bien combattu dans
les arènes romaines difficile de savoir
combien il était difficile aussi de
savoir l'âge à partir duquel les hommes
et femmes pouvaient entrer dans l'arène
le site vosgien a dû attendre les années
1960 pour que les archéologues s'y
intéressent à nouveau je crois que ce
qui est important tant que médiateur est
ce que j'essaie de faire passer aux
jeunes cessé de 2,2 de voir ce que ça
peut faire de milan une notion
chronologie qui me sens vraiment
vraiment capital en fait et puis ensuite
derrière bien sûr essayer de s'imaginer
à quoi ça pouvait ressembler
lui pourrait prétendre au titre de
gladiateurs des temps modernes tant son
courage semble sans limite alexandre
alain un sarthois de 26 ans atteint de
la mucoviscidose est greffée des deux
poumons participa dans quelques jours un
triathlon hors du commun 113 km à la
nage à vélo et à pied un défi colossal
que ce jeune homme relève pour lui et
les bienfaits d'une association enzo
maubert de la rédaction de lmtv sarthe a
pu le rencontrer lors d'une séance
d'entraînement regarder
ce sont ces derniers jours de
préparation
et c'est sur ses terres à
sablé-sur-sarthe qu'alexandre alain
centre elle voit le but et là quelques
jours de l'épreuve c'est de faire
tourner les jambes prendre prendre du
plaisir et et voilà fait pas forcé parce
que les prix varient de rapidement mais
c'est prendre du plaisir est toujours à
voir ses repères sur le vélo
car le 3 juillet alexandre atteints de
la mucoviscidose est greffée des deux
poumons affrontera ça un half ironman
une course hors du commun 1,9 km de
natation 21 à pied 90 à vélo un défi
qu'ils préparent depuis six mois il ya
forcément une part d'inconnu mais c'est
ce que je vais chercher aussi dans ce
genre de défi il ya une forme
d'excitation parce que ça y est les
après le long à l'entraînement et puis
on va essayer de prendre le maximum de
plaisir malgré la souffrance que chez
qui va être un peu présentait avec avec
le sport déjà en 2021 alexandre avait
gagné son pari fou de terminer le
marathon de paris
au delà de l'exploit c'est à chaque fois
un message qu'il tient à transmettre
tout mais des filles 50% ses personnels
c'est pour moi me prouver des choses
avancent et me construire mais à 50% si
pour toutes les autres personnes qui ont
pu l'être dans mon cas en attente d'une
greffe créé fait que ça se passe mal moi
aussi parfois ça s'est mal passé mais
j'en suis là aujourd'hui donc je suis la
preuve je suis pas extraordinaire six
mois j'en suis aujourd'hui tout le monde
en capacité de le faire le 3 juillet
prochain alexandre représentera
l'association grégory lemarchal aucun
doute qu'on le retrouvera bientôt dans
un nouveau défi peut être même le vrai
iron man celui des 2 166 km
séparant les rares et témoignent d'une
époque heureuse pour les français anne
aymone giscard d'estaing la femme de
l'ancien président de la république m'a
accordé un entretien exceptionnel dans
le cadre d'une diffusion prévue le 9
juillet prochain sur tv5 monde à 22
heures l'ex première dame de france est
notamment revenu sur son rapport à la
présidence la politique mais aussi les
territoires avec lesquels elle a noué
une relation très particulière
regarder et écouter en avant-première
cet extrait de l'émission avec un aymone
giscard d'estaing les gens
ne savent pas que vous avez été une
première dame des territoires
plus qu'aucune allant vous puisque vous
avez effectué
un voyage
mensuelle tous les mois quasiment dans
un des territoires français dans un
département français
en effet c'est moi qui l'ait décidé que
je pensais que c'était utile de marie
que vous a dit on pas du tout non non
non c'est une initiative de moi je
demandais à ce que pendant ces deux ou
trois jours je puisse voir le maximum
d'éléments de la vie locale ce que ce
soit
en effet la vie culturelle en voyant
même des monuments des musées des
artistes mais surtout au point de vue
social
j'allais dans les maisons de retraite
dans les
les maisons pour enfants
et puis la vie économique aussi j'ai
visité beaucoup le bus in de
lui même descendu dans une mine
j'essayais de le voir le maximum de ce
que comportait un chaque département
voilà les missions territoire de france
avec l'entretien exceptionnel que m'a
accordé anne-aymone giscard d'estaing
sera à découvrir le samedi 9 juillet à
22h sur tv5 monde allez on termine cette
édition avec un reportage rempli
d'odeurs et de couleurs estivales dans
la baie de somme la pêche aux coques bat
son plein en ce moment sur la plage et
dans un décor extraordinaire les
pêcheurs s'attelle tête baissée à
récolter les précieux mollusques leur
mission en ramasser un maximum avant la
remontée des eaux bien sûr reportage au
petit matin de jérémy houbron pour ueo
tv la chaîne de la voix du nord
c'est un ballet bien matinal à la pointe
du hourdel le soleil ne donne pas encore
à l'horizon que déjà les pêcheurs à
pieds prennent d'assaut la baie de somme
râteau en main il creuse le sable pour
en révéler les précieuses coque
voilà c'est de le calibrer là on
travaille comme ça parce que oui et
après on les met dans une veine grapesa
dans l'eau et puis on les gris blanc
rouge le petit qui n'a pas la taille il
descend
le temps est compté avant que les eaux
ne revienne à envahir les lieux alors le
nez au sol au son des vénètes les
quelques 200 pêcheurs ne chôme pas et
s'active pour remplir des sceaux de
mollusques un travail éreintant dans un
cadre hors du commun c'est comme tous
les métiers ça vous savez c'est une
habitude si on n'y pense pas j'ai envie
pas du tout celui qui est en baisse dans
un bureau vraiment que la porte fermée
nous on a une chance inouïe on a
vraiment une chance inouïe de travailler
dans un cadre pareil ils sont les seuls
habilités à pêcher des coques l'activité
et réglementer les coquillages sont
calibrés 27 mm minimum et leurs récoltes
limité à 96 kg par pêcheur le buteur
numéro connaissances
en deux heures les quotas sont atteints
preuve que cette année les gisements
sont riches à bicyclette les coques
rejoigne les camions destination les
marchés français et espagnol
pour l'heure impossible d'en connaître
la valeur marchande en attendant les
pêcheurs à pied écumeront lourdel toute
la semaine avant de repartir vers le
crotoy
c'est la fin de ce grand jt des
territoires merci de nous avoir suivi on
se retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle
édition au revoir à tous
[Musique]